- He's the founder of
Swedish high-performance
car manufacturer Koenigsegg Automotive.
He showed interesting
cars from an early age.
At six years old, he drove a go-kart
for the first time in his life.
He created the world's fastest road car,
which can go from zero
to 400 kilometers an hour
in just under 20 seconds.
He's Christian von Koenigsegg,
and here are his top
ten rules for success.
(whooshing)
(thump)
- [Narrator] In only 21 years,
Koenigsegg has come from nowhere
to be one of the highest
regarded hypercar manufacturers,
being counted alongside Ferrari,
Lamborghini, and Maclaren.
How have they pulled that off?
- Well, we had to work hard,
be a little bit innovative,
and don't believe in the hype
that it's impossible. (laughs)
But it's, you know, every day we strive
and push and learn and adapt.
And when do you do with that for 20 years
with a great focus within the group,
you can do pretty much anything.
I think that's the simple answer.
But for sure, it's not easy.
You have to be prepared
to work hard for it.
From a personal perspective,
my ambition has always been to build cars.
That's why I started my car company
at 22 years of age, 15, 16 years ago.
And that's all I've been doing since then.
And then this opportunity presented itself
to be able to build cars in a larger scale
with brand that was very dear to me.
And we jumped on this opportunity,
and here we are today.
So the Koenigsegg group, we
consists of entrepreneurs,
and if you look at all our track records,
whatever we started, we still have
and continue with and work
with to make it prosper.
And we have the same ambition with Saab.
We have gotten into this because
we want to live with Saab
and work with Saab for a
very long period of time.
It's not something we do short-term.
It's a long-term ambition.
And basically, we don't
do it because it's easy,
we do it because it's a
challenge, it's a real challenge
and it's a worthwhile challenge
where we can make a difference.
- [Christian] Well, as I
mentioned, I have this,
I saw this Norwegian movie when
I was about five years old.
And about this guy who built
a really interesting sports car.
And I remember saying to
myself that when I grew up,
that's what I want to do as well.
I want to build my own
car, cars, and sell them.
So that dream never left me.
So when I was 19, I
started my first company,
which was a trading company
to make really big money
with the ambition to use that
money to build my own cars.
And then when I was 22, I had
made a little bit of money,
and then I started the car company.
And that was in 1994,
which was 18 years ago.
- [Narrator] Koenigsegg
are fully independent
and manufacture their
cars entirely in-house.
We asked if this independence
is a benefit to them.
- I do, I do.
For example, with the Regera, I don't see
any of the other established
super hypercar brands daring
to remove shifting of gears.
It's such a fundamental thing
to take away from a sports car.
I think it's only Koenigsegg
that could make that decision.
And I'm very confident about the decision,
I'm very confident when people
experience that direct power,
that instant control
you get and directness,
that they will quickly understand why
that's a very good
alternative to shifting,
even though shifting is fun, nice,
and part of driving a sports car.
So for example, yeah, we
have more freedoms like that,
or take more freedoms like that.
Of course, we want to
infuse Saab with spirit
and kind of make people really
look forward to go to work
and they can, they feel that
they can make a difference.
It's basically about empowering people.
Saab is, from the Koenigsegg perspective,
from a Koenigsegg supercar
company perspective,
a very large company,
but still, it's people,
and they're developing
cars on a larger scale.
So we still think we can get
that kind of family feeling going,
but it's mostly important
to empower people
to know they can make a difference
and really work together.
I see the company as a part of my family.
And I guess I see our cars
like my children in one way.
I have two sons which I
love very, very, very much.
But also the cars are my babies somehow.
I really care a lot about them
and it's like a part of myself somehow.
I don't separate my own being
from the company or the cars.
We're really connected
together, and it's my life.
And I don't see my work as work.
I don't see it as my whole day.
It's just who I am and what I do.
I think it's one of our strength.
I mean, there are strength of
being a big car corporation
with all the resources you have at hand,
but there are also strengths
for a small founder-driven
sports car company
that we have to utilize to
compensate for the lack of size.
So, of course, we heard that all
the big brands in the
industry were creating
their next-level super
hypercar, hybrid cars,
and we were not sure what
they were coming out with.
We were assuming they
want to trump our car,
the Pagani, the Bugatti, in every aspect.
And simultaneously, we started
developing the One:1 program,
so we want to make sure we
overshot what we already did
by quite a margin, and maybe we brought it
little bit higher than we
needed to, we will see.
But I think it will
compare quite favorably
to these new hybrid hypercars.
But when it comes to us
competing with the big boys,
I think that's what
we've always been doing,
so that's nothing new.
It's really a David against
Goliath kind of scenario
that we're pretty used
to and are fine with
and enjoy at the same time, I would say.
So the motivation to create the One:1,
even though we already
had a superbly fast car
that also was good for track use,
was that some of our
customers really wanted more
of a cup car, a GT car,
just specifically developed for the track,
but they also came with the demand
that you should have full road usability
and full homologation, and
that was a bit of a challenge,
because what we ended up
building was more or less a car
that looks and feels like
a GT1 car on the track
but then you push a button, it raises up,
and you have all the creature comforts,
air conditioning, satellite
navigation, Bluetooth telephone,
air conditioning, whatever,
that our normal cars have.
But we have to save weight
and we have to have more downforce,
we had to have a stiffer chassis setting
when needed on the track,
and also lighter weight.
So yeah, that was the motivation
and that was the challenge.
Well, I remember when I started that.
First of all, there were many examples
of people starting car
companies, extreme car companies,
and not succeeding doing
it for different reasons.
And I remember saying to myself,
I have to start when I'm young,
because it's going to be very difficult,
it's going to take very long time,
but I am determined to do it,
even if it's almost impossible.
And I expected the, I
was coming from Sweden,
only 22 years old, I
expected everyone to say,
maybe not racing, but that is impossible,
you will never succeed, it's
just a dream, and so on.
I expected that.
So when I got that
response from many people,
it did not push me down,
because I was ready for that response.
And it kind of is, that
triggered me even more to say,
yes, I understand that you think that,
but I will show you that
it is actually possible.
And I get a lot of, now,
feedback and from people around
who see this and are doing
other things in other areas,
not only cars, but they say,
it says, you can do that,
anything must be possible,
so you made me believe in my dream,
and now I've done this and succeeded
and then kind of thank you, whatever.
And that is so great,
because it actually proves
that even hypercars can be
very beneficial to society
because it shows dreams
are possible, in one way.
So yeah, it's just like that, I guess.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Mopati Bogatsu asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of
the top 10 tips meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(thump)